[Musique]
quand on aborde le sujet de sa célébrité
l'une des grandes stars de l'art inuit
rigole le carnaval comme pipo pitot cuma
lui qui tout cas là est né à l'époque où
les inuit était encore nomades
la sculpture est partie de son adn des
animaux en pierre il commençait ans
cultive dès l'âge de 4 ans i want to
make something for je voulais un truc au
magasin et mon grand père m'a dit il
faut du mérite
il m'a donné une pierre et m'a montré à
sculpter se souvient l'artiste un canapé
ministre du raft crêpes ayew chasse
aujourd'hui à puvirnituq on retrouve les
oeuvres du sculpteur à l'aéroport à
l'école des visages figés dans la pierre
la culture d'un peuple qui en moins d'un
siècle est passé de l'igloo à l'internet
non hadopi pour nadine mois les jeunes
ne sculpte plus dit il
comme tous les jeunes du monde les
inuits habite un territoire virtuel ou
facebook leur est plus familier que la
bataille avec l'ours polaire
mais surtout on ne va plus autant
chasser dans le territoire où l'on
trouve la pierre
il n'a pas tort la pierre est loin dans
la toundra dit il
ils sont prêtes à sortir en avant donc
ça c'est un artiste en particulier de
admis une époque de inukjuak qui
malheureusement décédé en 2000
et c'est ici c'est des nouvelles nous
avait bien ça c'est de saluer et ce qui
est curieux on a arrêté de recevoir de
quelques clubs coopérative beaucoup
moins twitter tandis qu'ici en plus
jeunes qui ça milliards de pièces en
pièces ici c'est plus rapide
richard murdoch est en quelque sorte ni
dans la culture inuit
son père a participé à la création il ya
50 ans de la fédération des coopératives
du nouveau québec qui vend et distribue
au sud par du nord
au début du 20e siècle le commerce des
fourrures décline et zinio et doivent
trouver une alternative
quelque chose à vendre comme ils sont
habiles de leurs mains et travaillent
tous la pierre il commence à vendre des
sculptures à la baie du titre ont donc
commencé par faire des structures et ça
a bien marché dans le sud s'étaient très
apprécié médiatement on a vu tout de
suite les ouvrages qui est évident c'est
aussi la façon de voir la vie qui était
différente on la perd si beaucoup en
fait c'est un gros gros succès tout le
gratin montréalais sur en 1949 à la
première exposition d'art inuit au musée
mccord une mode est née à partir des
années 50 la sculpture devient une
source de revenus fiable pour les inuits
à puvirnituq par exemple les ventes de
la coopérative locale passe de 750 $ en
1952 à 100 mille dollars en 1962 tout le
monde s'est mis à sculpter on savait
tous que ma part ce qu'on faisait déjà
pas mal de choses avec la pierre des
lampes surtout
c'était le début des coopératives inuit
on y disait de fabriquer les années
qu'on trouvait ici phoque hawks polaire
la coi devant le ca au sud et ça nous
donnait des sous explique à l'aide tout
cas tout cas qui a participé à la
construction de cet immense inukshuk à
coude droit a fait au début des années
80 les ventes d'art inuit atteignent des
records justine glavic les coopératives
engrange des ventes annuelles de plus de
2 millions de dollars aujourd'hui les
recettes ont baissé du deux tiers
il y avait une époque que tout le monde
voulait avoir un en oeuvre d'art
cette idée cadeau pour des confirmations
des mariages des retraites etc
ce n'est plus la mode on peut utiliser
les deux sens du mot souvenir pour un
gars est un souvenir d'enfance et pour
un jeune c'est pour le marché des
souvenirs les boutiques de cadeaux
désormais la sculpture ne permet presse
la personne d'en vivre
les revenus que touche un artiste
nunavik pour sa production sont en
moyenne de 6 mille 600 dollars par an
alors qu'un ours s'apprête à mettre du
mains agiles depuis que boy
l'homme est un brin nostalgique nous
sommes
nous allions chasser nous connaissions
les légendes qui ont inspiré notre art
mais je suis convaincu que tout n'est
pas perdu
si les jeunes s'y mettait ils ont fait
capable
j